>> Man, oh, man.
I know everybody's been looking forward to
this, not supposedly seeing me, but it's the
end.
So I'm going to try to make this as quick
as possible.
I don't know, I guess, will my slides show
eventually?
I sure hope so.
Shout out to the AV people, because they're
the best!
[Applause].
All right.
The slides are supposed to show any don't
know.
I hope so, because I'm not going to be able
to act this out the whole time.
There we go!
So, quickly, I mean, I realise that I saw
a speaker yesterday, and she kind of like
matched her slides with her outfit, so I thought
I might do the same.
And so, if everything goes right, I'm going
to disappear!
And I'm going to re-appear again.
It's like camouflage!
Okay, it worked.
Anyway, I thought that was kind of funny.
And you're going to find out I'm a bit of
a comedian.
We will start this with a joke.
Is that cool?
Can we have a joke?
All right.
How many JavaScripters here?
I mean, it's kind of funny that I don't see
all the hands up, but that's cool.
So, imagine if naughty by nature went to the
TC39 meeting.
Hip-hop hurray!
Hey - oh, you didn't like that.
It's all good!
Anyhow, we're going to get things cracking.
My name's Henri.
My last name isn't Helvetica.
I thought it sounded cool.
I did anyways.
People might recognise me from my nays which
is the avatar that I kind of like to.
I'm from the greatest city on the planet called
Toronto.
It's super multi-cultural, and I didn't realise
it until I left, and I was like, man, Toronto
is actually amazing.
If you're in the area, check us out.
Here is something you may not have known about
Toronto.
Anyone own a Commodore 64 back in the day?
Commodore was founded in Toronto.
No doubt.
So we're going to get things going.
Welcome to the Shape of the Web.
It's a talk I thought about a while back,
and sort of just to talk about where the web
has gone.
A lot of good things have happened.
A lot of technology was used to make things
really sort of like friendly and - like the
great user experiences that we try to create,
but I also felt that the technologists that
were involved were amazing but some who may
have been left behind so we will have a conversation
about that.
It's really just a conversation.
So let's get cracking.
Now, first off, I want to thank JSConf EU
for having me.
I've been watching this conference from a
distance on Twitter and look at the photos
like this is amazing!
Look at the screen!
No, seriously, look at the screen!
I mean, I only an-wide at home, and I think
that this ratio is like 15:2 which is bananas.
Talk about neck pains.
DevTools would be amazing on this screen,
by the way!
First of all, X, ten years, and I come from
music, so I could appreciate what they've
done here, the set-up.
I mean, it's absolutely elaborate, but I love
that they've done this for a tech conference,
so can we please give JSConf a round of applause
as well!
[Applause].
All right, that's enough!
I'm going to get jealous!
So, they've been around ten years, and I was
thinking to myself, like, you know, I was
kind of writing this talk up, adding some
notes, ten years.
Where was I ten years ago?
Like I said, I came from music.
I was able to pull this photo out.
I used to do lectures with the Red Bull Music
Academy which is actually based out of Germany,
and I was doing a lecture here with Flying
Lotus, a big deal for me at the time, ten
years a week from today.
It's pretty on point and on brand.
But the web.
The web's actually 30 years old.
And I was thinking to myself, like, man, 30
years old, that's kind of like a long time.
And I don't know where you were 30 years ago,
but I remember when I first accessed the web,
the first thing I thought of was this.
And I don't know how many of you were able
to sort of like be around this time where
you had to get a modem, and you made those
telephone sounds, and that stuff, just to
get on the internet?
But it was great because I discovered a lot
of things, and there was one place I used
to hang out - who remembers newsgroups here?
There we go.
This is where I hung out a lot, rec.hipohop
and yes, I'm going to talk about hip-hop with
people I don't know.
This is the first time you start to connect
with people from all parts of the world who
had access to the net.
Another thing that I did, as I had more and
more access, I used to use search engines,
like everyone else, and who remembers Alta
Vista.
There we go.
I was a big fan.
When that vanished, I was so sad.
But, what I also did was I started to surf
the web, and I was a big Netscape Navigator
and Communicator fan.
Actually, there were a few browsers around
thereafter, but this is the one that I was
using, and the big part about this one is
when it was released, this is what one of
the early quotes from Andriesson himself,
"This software is going to to change everything."
And it did.
Another quote came, things started exploding
with the invention of the browser because
suddenly the internet was accessible to the
average person.
And I mean, average, we will say sort of like
model-class person who had a computer and
a modem, but it definitely opened things up.
You started to have that delight and discovery
that I like to talk about.
When Netscape came out, it was extremely popular,
65 million users in 18 months, and part of
the reason was the fact that as much as the
early web was, like, text, it was very academic,
they were actually able to bring images into
the fold here, and what then happened is that
when we were surfing the net, we were accustomed
to the lay-out text, images.
It was reading the paper.
And believe it or not, there was debate as
to whether or not they were going to bring
images on to the web.
Some mild arguments, and the belief was that
if they brought images on, there would be
like this onslaught of pornography.
And I'm here to say that they were absolutely
wrong.
Right?
But, the fact is, for real, though, they believe
that by opening it up, adding some images,
and letting people sort of expert, it was
going to drive the web forward, and it actually
did.
Now, today, we are 4.3 billion users online.
I think that's phenomenal, but believe it
or not, there's still room to grow.
And, you know, you might wonder that's an
explosive growth.
What sort of drove that?
Well, this is kind of it right here.
This young lady's on a mobile phone.
I believe this is nothing that the they expected
to see at the time.
This is like mid-1990s.
Who thought you were going to have a mobile
device and be able to surf the web just as
powerfully as they did back then?
So this has allowed us to do a lot of different
things.
We've been able to be very productive in life.
So what have we been able to do with sort
of like little friction?
Pretty much everything.
I mean, we can make money, we manage money
online, we can go on a date, we can go buy
clothes.
We can actually go rent a car to take your
date out.
We can order fish, we can listen to one of
my favourite songs called Fish, and we could
actually get phishing emails from African
Princes, right?
But all jokes aside, man, we can actually
read comics and make them accessible, comic
books, shot-out to Jessica.
[Applause].
No doubt.
For all the people that were trying to bring
online, we could actually go offline.
This is what technology has allowed us to
do.
Which is absolutely needed.
By the way, I downloaded the offline map for
Berlin because I was not going to pay those
fees.
But we could actually create music in the
browser as well.
Shout-out to Live :JS in the building!
This is what the technology has allowed us
to do, very important.
This is the shape of the web as we see it
growing right before our eyes.
So, the technology has been extremely important
in getting these sort of things done.
And this is where we are going to sort of
like see even more technology allow us to
do greater things thereafter.
Now, what about the technologist?
We may have been playing some amazing chords
on some of the devices that we've seen out
there, you know, from keyboards to the MIDI
controllers, but, unfortunately, there's been
a little bit of discord as well, and we're
going to get into a few items that have been
bothering me a little.
Let's talk about technology.
There's an ongoing refrain, we know exactly
what is going on, and it saddens me.
I mean, you just need to open up Twitter and
wait five seconds before it hits you, and
I think that's sad.
It's been long discussed, you know, what needs
to be done to retain talent, to attract talent,
and we still go out and sort of like trip
over some of the main issues.
I mean, what do they talk about?
What do women talk about when they leave the
industry?
The lack of career growth, salary, poor management,
and, you know, when I read poor management,
I know exactly what they mean.
That's just being polite.
And the other part is actually what scares
me, because the other, I feel, I know exactly
what is going on, but, again, it's being polite
and not calling people out, because other
to me means this.
It's not fit for print, but we know exactly
what is happening.
To me, that's absolutely not the way or the
shape of the web needs to take.
Further on I'm going to share a little story,
something I did did a few years ago.
International men's day happens once a year,
March 8th.
And I got together with some buddies, I'm
like let's rap about this.
I want to put an event for women to come out
and enjoy themselves and listen to other women
in the industry.
This goes back to something I tried about
ten years ago in music.
I really wanted to do a show with female producers.
I work in a certain pack of sound, and I knew
there were producers out there, but when I
went knocking on some doors, I couldn't find
any sponsors, so it got a little tough, but
I never forgot that.
When I had an opportunity to do something
again, I did.
So, every year we put together in event called
IWDTO, International Men's Day, and this is
a picture of 2015, and we've been doing it
for five years now.
On the right to left, we have Lisa, who worked
at the White House, an Obama hire, by the
way.
The lady in the middle, someone who I look
up to very much, she works in performance.
She goes by the name of Tammy Everts who works
at SpeedCurve.
An amazing person.
You need to follow her if you can.
On the left, I'm not sure if she is here,
Mina Markham.
I would be happy for her to come down and
share her story.
The most important part is the fact that,
like I say, we do this every year, and it
warms my heart to be able to help out in a
way - I might not be the best ally - but I
feel I'm doing something to make things work.
Why do I want to to this?
I want to make sure that we have moments like
these, you know?
[Applause].
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Katie, we know exactly what happened there.
A great moment, even though shortly after
we saw the trolls come out and sort of question
her.
Margaret Hamilton, as we know, coined the
term "software engineering" but right there
she is sitting next to the stack of paper
that was essentially her sort of like tracing,
or helping get the rockets up to the moon.
But one of my favourite photos is this one
right here.
This is the Indian space research organisation.
And they're having a ball right there.
Why?
Well, they were the fourth team to ever get
a satellite around Mars.
But they were the first to do it on the first
try, not NASA, not the European Space Agency,
and not the Russian Space Agency, but the
agency out of India.
As you can tell, the team is made up of several
women.
It's actually a short documentary on that.
I will be more than happy to put the link
out.
So I want to see of month of these happening,
these moments taking place.
The big thing is that the comment thread between
the three photos that I showed, I mean, they
all had CS backgrounds, degrees, and what
not, which brings me to my next malaise, the
CS versus non-CS beef.
Any CS people in the building?
I mean, raise your hand.
I've got love for you.
You know what I mean?
How did this happen?
I really don't know.
But, I kind of got triggered by this one tweet,
and this person's going to go unidentified,
reasons why computer science degree is a bad
eat.
Idea.
What?
Money, time, CS can be so boring.
I thought to myself that was irresponsible
because it came from someone who has a large
platform, and I actually questioned him on
it, but I'm not going to get into that.
But, I will get into this, and make some noise
when you see a photo that sort of like you
recognise the image.
[Applause].
Okay.
All right.
Does anyone know what this is?
Okay.
I'm go the to get into that, but does anyone
know what this is?
Okay.
So, let me go back.
Dartmouth Oversimplified Programming Experiment
- DOPE.
It was the language that preceded BASIC.
Why is it important?
The author of BASIC, a math wizard worked
at Dartmouth, believed that he could get non-STEM
students at the university to get into programming.
And he basically soldiered on trying to make
things work.
Eventually, BASIC did become a language, and
how did it happen?
Because he got a lot of non-STEM students
to work along and contribute to the venture.
And BASIC was born.
That's very important, because even as a non-STEM
student you're in BASIC, this is a tweet from
Brian Love's words boom!
I thought this was so true.
You needed to see this because you don't need
a CS degree to be successful, but it doesn't
mean by having a CS degree you're not going
to be.
In fact, John's daughter mentioned this: BASIC
was basically an incredible project of what
is now called an aligned team.
I thought that was wild.
But speaking of CS, I want to talk about something
else real quick.
Does anyone know who this is?
Probably not.
Her name's Lena Soderburg, and most of the
CS people, and if you're in performance, you
might know this performance, Lena?
We know someone here knows?
But you might recognise her when I do this.
Now, this is the photo that's been internationally
accepted as the test image when you do any
kind of image processing, compressing, et
cetera, et cetera, which is totally cool.
But here's what is not so cool.
This is where it came from.
I remember doing some research one day, and
I could not believe it.
We've been using an image from Playboy for
40-some years.
Do you know that two million images are uploaded
to the web daily?
Did I say two million?
I meant two million images.
They're uploaded to the web daily, but somehow
we have the photo of a centre fold as the
test image for image compression.
You know, for a second, I was thinking, it's
the 1940s, we're going to get over it, whatever.
It's going to fade.
This happened in 2018.
Someone presented a talk and just like talked
about centre folds - 2018.
How are you supposed to retain talent?
How are you supposed to attract talent when
you have this kind of comportment out in the
wild?
This is not the shape of the web to come.
And with that being said, I mean, I tweeted
this out just moments before I got on stage.
I will ask anyone who wishes to do so to vote
whether or not the Lena image should remain
the standard in image processing.
Now, we kind of know what this means, the
World Wide Web.
A developer I know likes to wall it the "wealthy
Western web".
Okay, I'm good, because I think this started
early.
I'm watching the clock and this flashing president
the wealthy Western web, because we like to
design and create apps for the West, but what
if I told you this is the list of the top-ten
internet users by country?
Okay?
What if I told you the greatest growth by
country looks like this: now, these two lists
are the reason why documentation is important,
and it's important to trans late.
Think about this.
Remember that German spoke yesterday who said,
he spoken a few times on stage but it was
his first time speaking in English.
First time.
And you have developers out there that are
trying to get in the fold, but documentation's
not in their native language.
That's something we definitely have to look
into.
Why?
Because you have situations like this.
And this sort of caused a little bit of kerfuffle
on Twitter.
And I was watching it.
And this tweet came out.
I'm not going to name the person, because
I didn't ask whether or not I could use it,
but this happened thereafter.
Same tweet.
Now, we are talking about, you know, creating
an inclusive community, an inclusive web.
I mean, I don't know how you're going to get
more inclusive than having documentation translated
properly so that other developers can have
some input.
Think about your framework that may sort of
like mature so much faster because you have
contributions from all over the globe because
they have documentation in their native tongue.
I think it's very important to remember.
That being said, what is next in 2020?
I don't know.
I think we will still be developers, and we're
all still going to love the web and go to
conferences, and network, we're all still
going to have great discoveries.
I mean, there's so much web we've yet to discover.
There are so many more people that we can
help the light in discovery.
I mean, there are so many more applications
we have yet to engineer.
People, neighbours, so many people we can
learn from, experiences, you know?
Just is that we can make tweaks to our applications.
At the end of the day, I know we are good
people by default.
I mean, I truly believe that.
I don't think that we are born with, like,
sort of like evil within us - at least I sure
hope not.
My hope is that we keep it as you have.
I mean, we get maybe one day to enjoy another
JSConf EU, because I would love to come back.
And, with that being said, thank you very
much for your time.
Come visit me in Toronto.
And let's party tonight!
[Cheering and applause].
Exit stage left.
I don't know!
Is anyone coming!
Is there a gong I'm supposed to hit?
[Applause].
>> I've got it, thanks.
I'm just joking.
Thanks, everyone, sorry.
We would like to thank everyone for coming.
And we would like to start with - we're going
to thank a lot of people now.
We want to thank all our speakers.
Please raise the roof for the speakers while
all the speakers come on stage to receive
your roof-raising, everyone, please!
All the speakers, please come on stage!
[Cheering and applause].
All right, so, ... [Applause].
So we have had a meeting about this, and I'm
glad you can see all the speakers and you
can do another applause, but then I need you
to go down for theatrical reasons which I
totally screwed up, very sorry.
One more big applause for all the speakers.
Thank you very much!
[Cheering and applause].
Now, we all need to go again so people can
see the slides we've prepared.
Sorry!
>> That's the main problem.
We have to ask speakers to leave the stage
again.
We need the screen!
Sorry.
Move to the side again?
Thank you.
Sorry for the confusion.
>> There was a meeting, and we talked about
it in Slack, and we got confused, mostly me.
It end like it started, with at least some
misunderstanding!
>> Very well prepared, yes, thank you.
Please, all the emcees and stage managers,
please stand up and receive your well-deserved
applause!
[Cheering and applause].
And the next group of persons and companies
we want to thank you are our sponsors.
Many of them joined us for more than one year,
some of them for almost ten years, and we
think that is worth a round of applause for
our sponsors!
[Applause].
>> People working at a company who is sponsoring
us currently, please stand up for a second!
Woo!
[Applause].
And also, sponsorship is our scholarship supporter
list.
That's the main reason why we need the screen,
because this list is really huge.
Please, everybody, stand up who is on that
list, and everybody else should give a warm
applause to all these people who made it possible
to include 150 people to our conference at
no cost.
[Cheering and applause].
And also, we want to say thank you to the
company called Attribute, who is bringing
all these parts together.
Attribute with Bjorn, Juliana, Andre, Philip
and the whole team is planning this event
to us and sets everything up with us, and
they're at least co responsible for everything
that you see here, and they're full of ideas,
and helped us growing over the years.
They joined us seven years ago, I think, and
it's a really great collaboration with them
so far, so thank you, Attribute, Bjorn, Juliana,
and everybody else!
[Applause].
The other companies that are here are Wecap.
Julia is doing our mood videos, Julia is doing
50 per cent of the photos alongside Shahin
who is doing the rest of our photos.
We want to thank the right?
Arena for hosting us for the last three years,
the Textile Press with us for three or four
years.
We had frozen yoghurt, and first time #nailconf.
We would like to thank Harald and his team
for the great food from the last three days.
We would like to thank you White Coat Captioning
who is captioning every stage at every time
of day and night via Skype calls set up from
all these stages.
We want to thank you the Bahn for the coffee,
and thank you to serve you for the Wi-Fi which
made roughly 200 megabits per second on average.
We want to thank you for childcare, the team
from Kids' Event, the medical response team
which helped us one or two times for difficult
situations this time, and we would like to
say thank you for those building the stuff
where you're sitting here.
Thank you!
[Applause].
>> Oh, wait?
I can already see what is happening ... . Oh,
my God!
That wasn't planned!
[Cheering and applause].
>> I've joined the luxurious land of post-conference
organisers, it's fantastic.
Can you all hear me?
Yes!
There we go!
Reaching out from the beyond to welcome all
of the JSConf EU organisers into the happy,
happy zone thereafter from - can everyone
give them a tremendous round of applause,
because tomorrow morning, they wake up without
worrying about yet another conference!
Congratulations, everybody!
[Cheering and applause].
Make them embarrassingly happy!
Congratulations.
If I make take a moment, we should reminisce
and appreciate the first time the JSConf EU
went off, I was in the same sort of role,
doing a video conference.
Clearly, I've not fixed this problem.
But things are as they are, so, I wanted to
take a second and congratulate everyone who
has organised JSConf EU throughout the years,
being a host, and many wonderful things, sliced
fingers opening for controllers, node.js,
housing one of the most inclusive and incredibly
diverse conferences, to proving that you can
do conferences outdoors in bubbles - yay!
- and you know what crazy people - and all
have a wonderful inviting, and wonderful experience.
You've done a tremendous amount of benefit
for the JavaScript and technology community,
and our thanks cannot - even if we thanked
you ever single day, it would not be enough.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
[Cheering and applause].
[Applause].
>> That's all I've got!
Auf wiedersehen.
>> All right, give it up for Live: JS!
[Applause].
Some of you have probably seen the talk yesterday
where they talked about how they created this
amazing experience.
You've seen them play over there.
They have not slept much over the last week,
and the weeks before this, it's been an incredible
amount of work, so, again, thank you very
much to Live:JS.
[Applause].
On top of that, we had a great set of artists,
who helped with the visuals, and especially
the mural over in the side track.
John was the person creating the audience's
programming, trailer, that ran at the start
of our opening show, and then we have the
group that created the absolutely incredible
computer of one's own exhibition that you
saw at the back of the of the hall.
We saw this earlier, you can now purchase
those.
Follow the link on our Twitter.
[Applause].
And then, Thursday, the week of last week,
so nine days ago, I messaged our internal
Slack for speakers, scholarship recipients
and volunteers saying we would like to do
a choir.
Can any one of you sing?
The response I got which what I was hoping
for we are a choir, we know what this is.
We're the awareness team, we're there anyway.
Can we help?
That saved our idea, and we had speaker and
scholarship recipients joining in our opening.
It was incredible.
They practised this the night before.
They had never met before, so give it up for
them.
Thank you very much.
[Cheering and applause].
>> We had the honour to get to have Wiebke
this year, she managed the sponsorship from
both conferences, and into and we could not
be more thankful to have her.
Big applause for Wiebke!
Such a big event couldn't be done without
the help of a team.
A big shout out to them.
They helped us for many things.
Thank you, Niko, Martin, Zeno, and Olivia!
[Applause].
This year, we had more volunteers than ever
before.
And they are the reason why we, the organisers,
could be a bit more relaxed this year.
They helped at the registration community
launch, BIPoCiT space, live captions, and
much more.
Thanks to all our volunteers.
[Applause].
So, who of you has been to the community lounge?
They shared great stories, right?
The community lounge is a small conference
running in the breaks since 2017.
Thank you, Michelle, and Vanessa, for being
part of our team and putting in so much effort
in organising the community lounge.
[Applause].
This year, for the first time, JSConf EU had
an inclusionary space for black, indigenous,
and/or people of colour.
Thank you Lauren, Darren, and Vanessa for
putting so much effort into the BIPoCiT space.
[Cheering and applause].
Also, for the first tile, we had a team which
was here for you in case you needed support
or had any issues.
Thank you to the team for their great work
and to Tui for organising it.
[Applause].
>> Our scholarship programme was organised
this year by Princya, Olivia, and Thuy.
Give it up for them.
[Applause].
JSConf EU would not be what it is without
the continuous help of the CSSconf EU team.
Thank you, Lukasz, Kristina for all your help
over these years.
>> Can you tell we didn't rehearse that bit!
Okay, thank you so much to the organisers.
I think that it's pretty obvious that this
is the most welcoming generate conference
in the world.
[Cheering and applause].
I think it's also really obvious that it's
changed the lives of probably 100s or thousands
of people, not just the in the room tonight,
but the people you spoke to, spread the word
to, and said, hey, the JavaScript community
is welcoming, friendly, and you can been a
part of it.
Thank you to all of you as well.
[Applause].
Okay, final announcement: we're selling the
portraits back there.
They are tweeted on the JSConf EU Twitter.
The money is going to go to the artist that
created them.
Next steps is in a second, we are going to
take a family photo.
It's going to happen straight behind us.
I need you to form a triangle, so narrower
in the front.
Ah, okay, more announcements, then we're going
to do the photo.
The photo's going to be shaped in a triangle.
Right now, let's remind you to get your things
from the coat check after we all come on stage.
So, first, everybody ...
>> I would say no, because I think I know
what I want.
Everybody who has helped this year organising
this great event, and who could not be on
stage because the slides are too big, please
come up.
We want you all here, and we want a warm applause
for all of you.
[Applause].
And now we would like to have the speakers
come to the stage again, please.
[Applause].
We would also like to have the speakers from
the BIPoCiT space and the community lounge
come to the stage.
[Applause].
Are our emcees already on stage in where is
our emceeing team?
Yeah!
Thank you, everyone for being here for helping
us, and please apologies for the unorganised
closing here.
We love you all, and I think we can go to
the family photo soon, but it's great to have
us all here, so thanks, everyone, again!
[Cheering and applause].